make news media said Roger stone will be
charged with treason Roger stone will be
charged with conspiracy against the
United States Roger stone will prove to
be the link between Russia and the Trump
campaign they could find no evidence of
any of those things
who is Roger stone they call me a dirty
trickster Patrick I have never
proclaimed myself back or called myself
that but if I am one that means I can
spot one and the Russian illusion hopes
is the greatest single political dirty
trick in American politics it's not easy
to be Donald Trump he got to the
presidency owing nobody he's been put in
the right place at the right time
for a reason let's say he doesn't pardon
you what do you do I'm very concerned
about this big government intrusion the
government spying on us is keeping meta
data information now they're tracking us
through our cell phones to see if we are
exposed to the virus not really the
reason their tragedies the story of
mixing is the story of resilience and
that's why I have a tattoo even on my
back the motors can spot a phony a mile
away Bill Clinton is a psychopath
Lyndon Johnson is the personification of
evil I'm prepared to do anything to
elect my candidate short of breaking the
law yeah well you're cutthroat meaning
you had no sympathy for beating
everybody yeah I mean your iPod no I
think that's unfair
I made people opportunity truth-telling
they don't want to hear the truth
nowhere as Jack Nicholson said they
can't handle
[Music]
did you ever think you will make you I
feel I'm suppose I could take sweet
victory I know this slice meant for me
yeah why would you feed on Goliath when
we got red tape value Taemin given
values contagious this world of
entrepreneurs we can't no value the
haters honey run homie look what I
become I'm the one
[Music]
my guest today may be the most
consistent controversial figure of
politics in the last four decades and
that's Roger stone this is a man that's
worked on the campaign of Richard Nixon
George Bush
we got Ronald Reagan as well as
President Donald Trump we had a lot to
cover with them here today so Rogers
don't thank you so much for being a
guest on Itanium Patrick I'm really
honored to be here you know and after 16
months of being unconstitutionally
gagged by a federal judge let's just say
I have a lot to say so I really welcome
the opportunity glad to hear that so
Roger the question for you before we get
into all these different topics that we
can get in talks and there's a lot of
different issues going on today I want
to hear your thoughts about where you're
at but there's one thing you say when
you say there's four stages of Fame
which is who is Roger stone get me Roger
stone get me a Roger stone type and then
who is Roger stone so one what does that
mean and two who is Roger stone well
that is a that's the cycle of a career
whether you're in broadcasting or sports
or entertainment or business when you
begin of course you're not well-known
when you accomplish things you are
well-known and people want your talents
after you no longer in the game people
want somebody just like you and then
over time people forget entirely who you
learn whether you left up mark on this
world my goal was to leave a mark on
this world
I have spent four decades fighting for
the things that I believe in and that is
constitutional Liberty the US
Constitution maximum personal freedom
small government a strong national
defense in the United States of America
and you take a lot of slings and arrows
people have to remember that when
someone wins an election that means
someone loses an election and the person
who loses the option is never happy
about it sometimes they are even
vindictive so you know I I have no
apologies to make I've spent four
decades in the rough and tumble of
America
politics and I called them as I saw and
although I am a Republican I really
believe that the Republican Democrat
divide is a hog Elian device that's just
used to divide us the real divide in
America is between the insiders who have
run things for 30 years and an outsider
in this case Donald Trump someone comes
to Washington and completely threatens
to upset the status quo who who halts
the country's haunting over the cliff to
globalism which is why the two-party
duopoly the political establishment in
Washington has been so anxious to get
rid of this man because he threatens
their cozy little relationships he
threatens the way they have lined their
pockets at the cost of the American
people so you know I have nothing to
apologize for politics ain't beanbag as
they say and I've given as well as I've
gotten but there's one thing I do object
to I keep reading in every article about
me over the last year self-described
dirty trickster Roger stone or
self-proclaimed dirty trickster Roger
stone or as CNN said the other day Roger
stone who has proclaimed himself the
dirty trickster of American politics
Patrick I have never proclaimed myself
that or called myself that I have
pointed out that others have called me
that I've said that I'm consigned to the
fact that it'll be in my obit probably
on my gravestone but I have not engaged
in any activity that isn't the same as
the activities of my contemporaries and
most specifically I'm prepared to do
anything to elect my candidate short of
breaking the law that I haven't done so
but but the question I want to ask is
who is Roger stone so for example if I
wasn't high I mean I know the stories
about in your in high school when you
know you you were looking at the
election and John F Kennedy was running
and you know you're looking at the two
and you're going out there saying you
know I think they're gonna make school
day on Saturday and you are
he knew how to get people to be
convinced on different sides but if I'm
in high school with you and you're not
1718 I'm talking to the 14 year old
Roger stone who was the 14 year old
Roger stone well let's see the 14 year
Roger stone was someone who lived in a
rural area where there were no children
my age within 25 or 30 miles you know
what that means Patrick no basketball
you know baseball no football no team
sport becomes available to you so now
you're relegated to sports that you can
do by yourself like long-distance
running or weightlifting it makes you
more of a loner I guess I'm the oldest
of three children my sisters are much
younger than that than I am I was the
president of my class and the president
of the student body in my high school
two years in a row having been elected
as a junior and also elected as a senior
unprecedented I started studying how to
get people to vote the way I wanted them
to as a psychological experiment very
early I'm a Roman Catholic I got all my
sacraments in the church I am I don't
believe every iota of Roman Catholic
dogma but I'm very recently reaffirmed
my belief in Christ it's helped me
enormous ly get through this ordeal in
which the full weight of the federal
government is placed on you in an effort
to get you to do something dishonest in
my case testify falsely against the
President of the United States it takes
enormous fortitude to refuse they they
hold out a path to that would take all
the pressure off of you that would
relieve all your personal and financial
and family stress and I simply said no
and I had to pray to God for support in
that decision I realize this is not a
religious program and I'm not trying to
proselytize but I am trying to answer
your question about Who I am what my
father I'm a grandfather I'm a great
grandfather I found great solace in the
support of my family during this
entire ordeal my wife
Nydia who's suffering from rheumatoid
arthritis has completely supported my
decision to plead not guilty to not roll
over on the president even the Shiina
even though she knows our paths might
have been easier had we done so she's
been behind me 100% and she suffered
through the late nights of anxiety and
the panic attacks and the other things
that people don't see
but I'll never quit fighting I'm not a
quitter
people asked me about my reverence for
Richard Nixon who I met as a very young
man and who was really my mentor in
American politics now there is no
question that Nixon made some egregious
mistakes but he also accomplished some
very great things he was a peacemaker he
got us a strategic arms limitation
agreement with the Soviets opened the
door to China and did the war in Vietnam
desegregated the public schools same
Israel in the 1973 Yom Kippur War many
great accomplishments but that's not
really why I revere him I revere him
because he was indestructible because he
got knocked down again and again and
again and as I think it was Vince
Lombardi who said it's not how many
times you get knocked down it's how many
times you get up the story of Nixon is a
story of resilience it's the story of
persistence it's an American story and
that's why I have a tattoo of him on my
back it's not a political statement it's
not a joke it's a daily reminder that in
life we particularly when your hand did
nothing you have to just keep fighting
for what you believe in so so the
question back in high school is were you
the guy bullying or will you the guy
that was bullied which one were you I
was more of the guy who was bullied
because I had no aptitude for sports
I wasn't among the jock set and because
I wasn't a pothead I wasn't among the
hippie contingent which was just on the
rise when I was in high school so I had
to appeal to both groups for votes
and
had a pretty successful highschool
political career it's interesting that
the New Yorker magazine wrote a long
piece about my high school years
never once bothering to interview me I
won my election as a student body
president 981 to 61 but somehow the
people at The New Yorker managed to find
the 61 people they couldn't find the 981
that voted for me so you were the one
that was bullied I think so yeah I mean
you know I had I would be tormented on
the school bus because I was carrying
political books and interested in topics
that no one else cared about the 1968
election took place when I was in high
school and I was a very big supporter of
the comeback of Richard Nixon nobody
else in my class cared about the
election they were all interested in
sports or girls or cars and all these
other things but I was interested in
politics
you know for somebody to take it to the
levels that you took it where you don't
take not I mean one of your rules is
your ten rules is what you're saying the
fact that you know attack attack attack
never defend you know always be on the
offensive you know all these things that
you talk about with your ten rules we'll
get into that here in a minute is for
somebody to be that shippi and to have
that kind of a drive to go beat the
opponent whatever it takes in the most
creative way
there has to there has to be an event
that really moved you as an individual
was it an event that really pissed you
off and you said I'm gonna prove a point
was there a woman that left you public
humiliation or loss and ass-whooping was
there anything like that that happened
that created the fire in you or was it
just this is how you were born from day
one well I guess I had some resentment
of the fact that my parents didn't they
didn't make it through high school
they were very hardworking religious
people we were lower middle class not
upper middle class I saw of the
privileged kid
in my school whose parents gave them
clothes and cars and nice vacations so
yeah I had some resentment and that
resentment drives you it drives you to
succeed it drives you to demonstrate
that you are as good or as better means
you have to work harder means you have
to be more dedicated but we did that you
know my father was a well digger that's
what he did for a living he and his
brother ran a company where it was a
rural area so if you owned a home you
had drill your own artesian well and put
in your own pumping system if you wanted
to have drinking water or water to bathe
whether up with and he ran an
old-fashioned chop drill we are
essentially a metal bit hits the ground
over and over and over again he would
leave for work every morning about 6:00
5:30 6:00 he would come home at the end
of the day around 6:00 completely
covered with mud just taped with mud my
mother would hose him down in the
backyard then she would serve him dinner
and then he would go to bed and he would
wake up the next morning and do the
exact same thing every day six days a
week Sunday we went to church and he
took the afternoon off you know Patrick
I never heard him complain not once did
I hear him complain but I can tell you
this when I introduced him to Ronald
Reagan in Norwalk Connecticut and said
governor Reagan this is my dad I could
not have seen my father be prouder of me
and everything I had accomplished in his
own way he was a great man a simple man
a man who believed deeply in his
Catholic faith a man who believed it
very much in thrift and hard work but a
man who gave everything so that his
children could be educated and have a
better life that's a that's a very
interesting when you're telling that
story about where you were out so now
privileged kids so you're grown up
around privileged kids typically when
somebody is raised around privileged
kids and you experience some of that
anger my dad worked at a 99-cent store
so I relate the fact that you know when
your dad works at a 99-cent store in
Englewood your parents get a divorce you
kind of got a little bit of a chip on
your shoulder but typically when you're
around others that are privileged
wouldn't you become a Democrat instead
of a Republican what caused you to want
to become a Republican over being a
Democrat when I was 11 years old just
before I turned 12
the woman who lived next door to us who
was wealthier than we were but very nice
lady gave me a copy of a book called
conscience of a conservative by Barry
Goldwater and until that time I had
aspired to be an actor who I wanted to
be was an actor and my parents of course
kept saying no son you need to learn a
trade you should be a plumber or an
electrician or you know our carpenter
those people make really good money and
I said no I want to be an actor I want
to be on Broadway I want to be in films
I want to be on television they realized
that had I tried that I want to starve
to death but once I read this book I was
I was transfixed I now knew exactly what
I believed in it was the first time I
had seen anybody codify the things that
I felt that we needed a strong national
defense that we needed to limit the size
and cost of government that we needed
maximum personal freedom that communism
was inherently evil and that it was a
real danger to our society
and that this was the greatest country
on the face of the planet and the people
who founded it had undergone
extraordinary hardships to build the
Union that we enjoy today and I knew at
that point that I wanted to be in
politics there was a brief period of
time when I thought about being a
candidate but I'm really not the
extrovert that I tried hard to be I'm
actually somewhat more introverted and
therefore I became more interested in
the mechanics of politics of the back
room of politics of how to get people to
you know to legitimately of course vote
the way you want them to the use of
sophisticated polling data and
advertising techniques and messaging and
that end of
politics and then I figured out that
politics was really show business for
ugly people and I never looked back
business for ugly people Hey
but by the way you talked about earlier
when you were talking about the Trump
you mentioned the fact that insiders and
outsiders and you said here's a trump
that's coming up from an outsider wanted
to compete with a bunch of insiders but
but he got somebody like you to help him
I wouldn't you be like the Capitol
insider too yet because if there's
anybody that's an insider it's you
wouldn't that be the case when he hired
you I don't think so I mean first of all
I think we have to have the context I
met Donald Trump when I was working for
governor Ronald Reagan in 1979 preparing
for the 1980 election I was assigned New
York State as well as New Jersey and
Connecticut for Ronald Reagan in 1980
those are very tough States the rap on
Reagan was you know he's another
Goldwater he's an extremist the party we
get decimated if we nominated him we
need someone more moderate or maybe even
someone more liberal the Republican
establishment in New York State was
supporting George HW Bush guy who
couldn't figure out whether usually
Connecticut for Texas the cowboy boots
and the pork rinds didn't fool anybody
they grew up in Greenwich dude be who
you are I walked through Tom Kane the
governor of New Jersey he was the
ultimate wasp we had a strange accent
he had strange mannerisms but he never
tried to be something he wasn't and
people loved him because he was genuine
we've elected 40 patricians in this
country the working people voted for
Franklin Roosevelt how a more patrician
could you get it's the politician who
tries to be something they're not that
the voters can see through immediately
this is what I love so much about Trump
what you see is what you get he's
unscripted
he's unmanaged he is he is unhandled he
is uncontrolled he owes nobody he got to
the presidency owing nobody no special
interests not Wall Street not the banks
not the insurance companies not
the defense industry he got to the White
House all week only the American people
and therefore he's completely
unrestrained in what he can do he owes
no special interest and he's
extraordinarily independent I mean no
one tells him what to think what to say
where to go who appoint what to do and I
think the American people find that
refreshing he's also not politically
correct so he may not be eloquent but
he's always articulate you always know
exactly where he stands which is why as
early as 1988 I began thinking of him as
a presidential candidate I was right in
my assumption that over time that the
country would tire of career politicians
from both parties who promised great
things in election time and then never
deliver them we've had we had Clinton
Bush Obama they were all gonna withdraw
our troops from Afghanistan and Syria
and Iraq and they're still there you
know it it's like changing the pins on
the the soil diaper of a baby but
leaving the diapers in place nothing
really changes the rhetoric at election
time say between Romney and Obama they
tried very hard to sound different but
when you get right down to it other than
maybe in the area of tax policy but they
were offering you was exactly the same I
knew what Donald Trump it would be
different that he wanted to take the
country in a completely different
direction and I I know this because I've
known him for 40 years he didn't run
because he needed to be President he
didn't run because he wanted the pomp
and circumstance or the prestige or the
name ID or the beautiful house or the
great plane he ran because he saw the
country being run into the ditch and he
got tired of it
the one thing in business that he hates
more than anything else is waste and
being taken advantage of and he saw
America wasting money and being taken
around the globe and the point finally
came where he had to do something for us
for his country not for himself he's
lost billions in this job and he has to
suffer the daily by two per Asian and
the tsunami of hate and false
accusations against him and his family
every single day which would fell a
lesser man but who just gets right back
up and gets right back in their face and
keeps fighting so he's a person of
enormous courage
he's also and I can tell you this
firsthand I worked for Richard Nixon I
work for Senator Bob Dole who by the way
is a great American patriot
they're both very tough guys but Donald
Trump is tougher than either one of them
he's actually the toughest individual
I've ever dealt with
when he buddies in something when he
sets his mind on something he will there
is no limit to his drive to accomplish
it who comes second to his level of
Drive that you work with you work with a
lot of different personalities Bob Dole
Nixon Reagan Kemp the list is a long
list who comes close to him well it's
very hard I think my answer might
surprise you senator Arlen Specter you
know why because he lost the race for
mayor district attorney governor and US
Senate before he finally won a race for
the US Senate that's Drive that's Drive
so so would you would you consider
yourself almost just to kind of get an
idea and I'm not talking about the
lobbyists side of it we'll get to that
here in a minute but do you see yourself
somebody as like in Hollywood there's a
manager that has talent that they
represent or in the NBA NFL there's you
know agents and managers that represent
a certain talent but are you somebody
that you sit there and you actually look
at people and say that guy can be a
president one day that guy has what it
takes I think she's got it I think he's
got it is that how you look at people
when you see talent I think that's true
yes I think I can assess political
talent which you know is a combination
in the television age in the mass media
age of charisma of ability to
communicate the ability to talk as you
know
sure understandable sound bites the most
dangerous thing in politics is not being
wrong the most dangerous thing in
politics is being boring when a
candidate for public office is boring
when they really have nothing to say
when they play it safe and they just
keep producing platitudes for the
American people voters view politics
like the new entertainment boy the show
is boring I think I'll turn the channel
they turn you off and they start to look
elsewhere there's nothing more dangerous
in politics than trying to ride out the
clock when you're in an election going
into the homestretch and you're ahead by
say five points and therefore you decide
in the closing days to say nothing
controversial to not rock the boat
when you're sitting still in politics
you're losing you're only gaining when
you are moving and moving means taking
risks expressing ideas being out there
on the cutting edge and entertaining the
voters and engaging them in a way in
which they see something interesting in
your candidacy so are you saying if
Romney would have hired you he would
have been president well that guy was so
phony I'm not true even I could have
elected him I mean he was in three
debates and he was three different guys
three or four times as I said earlier
the motors can spot a phony a mile away
a guy who says I'm severely conservative
no conservative would ever describe
themselves that way mitt was not a
conservative Mitt didn't even become a
Republican until he decided to run for
the US Senate against Ted Kennedy and in
that race he ran to Kennedy's left on
everything
you wouldn't think there'd be any room
to Ted Kennedy's left then he came back
to run for governor and he ran again as
a liberal Republican and then when he
decided he wanted to become president he
started calling himself a conservative
but there's a lot of family tradition
here recognize his father Governor
George Romney of Michigan he knifed
Barry
water in the back just the same way Mitt
Romney knifed Donald Trump in the back
people need to understand the background
here Romney decided to run for the US
Senate in Utah a state that he does not
live in at the gilens property there but
he lives in Massachusetts or he did then
sure there's a long Romney family
tradition in Utah but the state
treasurer a Republican Trump supporter
very popular he wanted to run for the
Senate so MIT Romney prevailed on
President Trump to muscle the State
Treasurer out of the race and endorse
Mitt Romney for the Senate all of which
the President did in the gesture of
peacemaking for which Mitt Romney turned
around and stabbed him right in the back
at to MIT I remember that one that took
place by the way so just out of
curiosity would you compare a Romney and
the way he campaigned to how Kerry
campaigned what two decades ago kind of
some of their challenges because there
was a little bit of the flip-flopping
and whatever I could say to win an
audience over well the problem of course
is that neither one of them had any
could relate to the common man I mean
the great thing about Trump is while he
may be a billionaire he can relate to
the common person he can even relate to
the cab driver in the bricklayer and the
you know and the waitress in the diner
because he speaks colloquial English he
talks the way people talk I mean there's
a famous story about John Kerry going
into a Boston bar and saying around for
the house of course all the working men
cheer and then he says and I'll have a
comma CA and a snifter it's a perfect
example of the elitism of both Mitt
Romney Mitt Romney never had the same
hair color in any of the debates there's
just nothing genuine about him he's a
guy reading a script written by other
people
whereas Donald Trump doesn't have a
script there's no 28 year old
speechwriter somewhere saying here mr.
president here you're talking points
it's not how it works with Don from
that's because he's not a politician
he's the leader of a political
movement but he's not a politician he
never really aspired to be a u.s.
senator he toyed with running for
governor and fortunately he became
convinced that Albany was too small for
him which it was his destiny was to be
right where he is
I think he was the right man at the
right time to stop this country from
hurtling over the cliff to globalism
I think he's not only was he the own was
he the Republican who could beat Hillary
Clinton he was actually the only
Republican who could beat Hillary
Clinton why do I say that if you look at
Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania and Ohio
in those blue-collar working-class
Democratic drinks precincts
he runs five to seven points ahead of
where Mitt Romney ran or where John
McCain ran he could win the votes of
working-class Democrat union member
moterz where they couldn't why because
he's a regular guy he's not a stiff and
those folks can spot a stiff a mile away
and he's also not a cranky old man like
John McCain was that is so true the fact
that working man they're around other
working men and in their body language
is what they're looking at so they can
see when they're looking at certain
people on what go through and what's and
what not to vote for you know sometimes
you watch the news and you watch times
and you watch people's behavior men's
behavior change based on who the
president is when Clinton was president
you saw a lot of people take some of his
style when Obama was president it was
his style when Bush was president they
took a little bit his rage and senior it
doesn't matter Trump you can go back and
forth in sports you know you look at
someone and you'll say you build a team
around what position and basketball it
changes sometimes source you need a
center well today's not gonna Center
League it's been a more shooting guard
league or you need a point core all this
other stuff when you look at talent they
don't look the same they don't talk the
same Reagan talks very different than
Trump Trump talks very different than
Obama Obama talks different than Bush
bush senior you know JFK Nixon you go
and look at a lot of these candidates
what are some no matter
what's you need for somebody to have the
goodies to become the present United
States it's a very hard thing to put
your finger on but in this age of mass
communication in the age of television
whether it's really now cable or
satellite or broadcast TV I think
there's a certain charisma a certain
magnetism a certain size I don't mean
physical size although Donald Trump is
very tall and very broad shoulder but in
1988 the first time I tried to convince
Donald Trump to run for president and he
was shall we say mildly amused by my
idea I arranged for him to speak to the
Chamber of Commerce in Portsmouth New
Hampshire a couple months before the New
Hampshire primary and we took his black
helicopter from New York to to New
Hampshire there were more people there
to watch the helicopter landing than
who's shown up for Vice President George
Bush at the same location about two
weeks previously I think it was a
Chamber of Commerce lunch was sold out
so they had to set up speakers in outer
rooms so more people could hear in the
speech it was the largest crowd they'd
ever had and what did he talk about why
are we getting ripped off by our allies
in NATO why are we paying a
disproportionate share for their defense
I could understand it after World War
two when they were economically
decimated and we were wealthy but now
our economy is struggling and they're
wealthy why aren't they paying their
fair share if I were president I'm not
running for president folks but if I
were president I'd make them pay their
fair share what and this is pre NAFTA
what about these trade deals we are
getting ripped off they're really good
for our trading partners but they move
all the jobs abroad this is 1988 an
amazing consistency but more importantly
I saw the electricity of the crowd
I saw the way they reacted they were
stomping waving their napkins I mean
there was an energy in the room that you
rare
they see in politics and this wasn't
even technically a political speech and
I realized then that my instinct was
correct that Donald Trump could be
president if a time would come that he
wanted to be but 1988 he still had real
estate mountains to climb
he still had real estate projects he had
not yet accomplished the time was not
right with the American people they were
still electing career politicians
expecting something different but
getting exactly the same thing I wanted
him to run again in 2000 the late Ross
Perot
very well-known there where you are in
Dallas and then governor of Minnesota
Jesse Ventura who had a relationship
with with Donald Trump from his days
wrestling at the Trump casino in the
Trump Plaza in Atlantic City
urged him to run to give the president
all deference all deference I think you
know he would tell you today well that
was more Rogers idea than mine I did my
best to convince him we made some
exploratory efforts he spent some money
on polling but he ultimately concluded
correctly that one had to be either a
Republican or a Democrat to be elected
president that the mechanism did not
really exist for the election of a third
party or an independent candidate that
you could not get into the national
debates either by lawsuit or any other
reasonable way it's really a closed job
and that he would have to be either a
Republican or a Democrat if he ever ran
then for two years he would just needle
me and say you know I think I'll run
into demo just just because he knew I
would I would go insane and but it was a
joke between us and he his parents were
both who I knew very well great people
great people they were both hardcore
Goldwater Republicans Reagan Republicans
Donald was a registered Republican his
whole life until he briefly shifted to
the independence party in New York which
was the affiliate of the Reform Party so
he would be technically eligible to run
for the reform nomination in 2000 the
day after he decided not to run he
switched back to the Republican Party
and he was on the Ronald Reagan Finance
Committee for New York State that's how
we met and how he became friends so he
has actually always politically been
there I remember when he was running for
president and many conservatives kept
saying he's not a real conservative
really look at these judicial
appointments look at these tax cuts look
these were regulatory cuts look at the
way he's rebuilt our military strength
I think his credentials have been more
than proven so you know when you're
talking about the President Trump the
Chamber of Commerce event that you set
up that he went up and he started
talking about all these different things
it almost reminds me the story of how
Reagan when he got hired by GE I'm sure
you've read this order you know about
this where he would go around giving
speeches they were paying on
million-dollar your income and he was
supposed to talk about how special of a
company G is and he couldn't help
himself from talking about politics and
eventually they had to let him go
because it was too much politics and it
wasn't enough about what GE stood for
and the kind of a it was you know
frustrating GE do you think a part of
again I'm going back to seeing the
foundation of somebody that you look at
to say this person's got what it takes
to one day go run for it do you think
it's a person that goes out there and
does something where eventually they can
become a president if you look at a
Nixon he got the job done became a
president if you're looking at a Reagan
if you look at a Bush if you look at a
Trump each one of them had a different
thing that led them to become a
president what would you say was each
one of their strengths that helped them
become a president well I think in
Donald Trump's cases a couple of things
one he had built a successful
multibillion-dollar business number two
largely because of The Apprentice
everybody in America knew who Donald
Trump was the greatest challenge for a
presidential candidate let's take Marco
Rubio for example yeah I live in Florida
I know who he is let's go out on the
street outside your studio and that's
the first seven people we see who Marco
Rubio is and they're going to tell you
they have no idea so in the stage
is of a presidential campaign normally
speaking step one is to become
well-known you can't tell people of what
you stand for if they don't even know
who you are Donald Trump had the ability
to completely not have to go through
that because from day one people knew he
was the most successful entrepreneur in
the country if not the world
he already had a brand he'd worked very
hard to build that brand Trump stood for
success
Trump stood for quality Trump stood for
victory Trump stood for integrity in the
real-estate interest industry everybody
understood that a Trump building would
be first class that everything would be
top-of-the-line whether it's the marble
or the glass or the chrome or the design
it would always be the best and even in
the later years when he would he would
franchise his name those agreements
allowed him to control the quality of
what was being built so that his name
would never go on anything that was some
standard even if he owned a minority
piece of it I think that was a very
smart business thing because he did not
want to dilute the brand name which
stood for quality the the stature of
having that high name ID the courage to
say exactly what you think not to be a
politician who sticks a wet finger in
the wind to find out Lakes which way the
wind is blowing in order to say things
that will be popular what can I say that
will be popular as opposed to Donald
Trump who says I'm just going to tell
you what I think and voters I think
found that refreshing the Trump was
interested people know he's unscripted
they know you never know what he might
say let's tune in this could be
interesting where is all these other
candidates particularly Hillary Clinton
everybody knew that every word coming
out of her mouth had been told and
round-table did and focused groomed and
studied it was
completely phony that was also I think
in some cases mistaken when you
denigrate your opponent's supporters as
deplorable and by the way that was no
mistake that was a planned in Seoul you
are alienating people who may under some
circumstance consider voting for you you
can attack your opponent but why would
you attack the people voting for your
opponents so that was Trump how about
the other candidates that you work with
Nixon Bush Reagan what was their mo that
help them become presidents Reagan is
you know it's interesting because Donald
Trump has some of the qualities of each
of them like Ronald Reagan Reagan was a
big-picture guy
Reagan was more than happy to leave the
details of governing to his appointees
he focused on the big picture whether it
was no tax increases whether it was
rebuilding the military whether it was
taking a hard line against the Soviets
remember he inherited day time and the
underlying premise of date on under
Richard Nixon and dr. Kissinger was that
we would never beat the Russians in the
arms race and therefore we had to find a
way to coexist with them the shift to
Reagan is very dramatic
Reagan takes a new position no we will
beat the Soviets and our arms build up
required them to try to compete which
are then collapsed their economy and
down came the wall Reagan was very
focused on the big picture Trump is very
much like that very focused on the big
picture
Nixon however has I should say Trump has
Nixon's persistence Nixon's stubbornness
and I don't mean that in a negative
sense I mean it in the positive sense
that when he believes something when he
sets out to achieve something he won't
be deterred he and as I said earlier
Trump as much of Nixon's toughness in
terms of say Dwight Eisenhower who I
think is really underrated is one of our
greatest presidents because of his
self-deprecation in other words he liked
to kind of act like the bumbling old
general didn't really know what he was
doing but he was very smart and very in
control of our government and we had
unprecedented peace and prosperity under
Dwight Eisenhower so Trump is trued like
Eisenhower I doesn't show all of his
cards like Eisenhower so I think he has
many of the same qualities of those I
consider our greatest presidents what
would you say on the other side with
Obama with Clinton and with Jimmy Carter
these are the last three presidents or
even John F Kennedy what were their
strengths well John F Kennedy of course
if he were running today would be would
have to be a Republican because he was
an ardent anti-communist he wanted to
return to either a gold or a silver back
dollar he will he was worried about an
arms race with the Soviets he wanted to
get ahead of the Soviets he was a strong
for strong national defense people don't
recognize this but Kennedy won the 1960
election over Nixon by running to
Nixon's right the missile gap cui Moy
and Matsu in the Red Chinese Menace the
threat of Castro only 90 miles off our
shore which he accused the night Nixon
eisenhower Eisenhower next
administration I'm not doing enough you
know I think when Joe McCarthy went in
the voting booth he probably voted for
Jack Kennedy having beaten Jack's sister
rather than his Senate colleague Richard
Nixon
so John Kennedy was would have been had
he lived one of our greatest presidents
now one of the greatness not misnomers
of course is that he did anything for
civil rights he did nothing for civil
rights he talked about it he campaigned
on it he promised it but his Vice
President Lyndon Johnson convinced him
over and over again that it was too soon
to have a Voting Rights Act it was too
soon to have an open housing act it was
too soon to have a open you know a voter
a motor protection system and of course
as soon as Jack Kennedy was murdered
Lyndon Johnson did all those things that
he had reserved for himself
going from a hardcore segregationist who
as Senate President had killed every
single piece of civil rights legislation
other than the 1958 civil rights bill
into its Johnson inserted a poison pill
saying those indicted for civil rights
crimes would be tried before state
rather than federal juries well-known
Mississippi or Louisiana or Georgia jury
would convict the white man of a crime
against a black man in 1960 so Lyndon
Johnson who was a segregationist and a
hater his entire life is now remembered
as the civil rights president how ironic
it is it is in the case of the other
presidents you mentioned Obama Obama had
enormous talent it's very hard to
understand how he came from nowhere to
somewhere so quickly how he went from
being essentially a complete unknown
then he gives an electrifying speech at
the National Convention which makes him
a national candidate you can remember
the famous conversation recounted in Ted
Kennedy's book where Bill Clinton says
to Ted Kennedy this point Obama I don't
know Ted a few years ago he'd be
carrying her bags and serving our coffee
interesting you know I think Obama was
very talented in his ability to
communicate on my own wife considered
voting for him because he was robbing us
hope and change he left us with neither
but very politically talented also very
cool
in a medium you know in a television
medium that requires that very effective
I think Jimmy Carter like Reagan in a
way in over his head
swallowed up immediately by the
Washington establishment who really
didn't want him to begin with he
won the nomination and the presidency
completely based on an outsider strategy
based on most solely on the voters
revulsion over Watergate but he got
swallowed up immediately by Brzezinski
and sigh dance and all of these other
establishment figures who essentially
destroyed his presidency he also was
extraordinarily indecisive and I don't
think you could see that coming when
things in the country turned down the
economy was weak we were being
humiliated around the world instead of
taking action he blamed the country we
have a national malaise
you may remember by the way he's the
only former Democratic president who
when I met treated me quite well he was
very warm and I enjoyed the opportunity
to talk to him he was a complete
gentleman Bill Clinton is a psychopath
read my book the Clintons war on women
he's charming he's a rogue he's very
convincing but he is a he's a serial
assaulter of women it is fully
documented I really think that he is a
functioning psychopath who who do you
dislike more himself or LBJ Lyndon
Johnson is the personification of evil
if you read my book the man who killed
Kennedy certainly case against LBJ which
is uh still in New York Times bestseller
still is quite well he was a sadist he
was a crook he was an alcoholic he was a
pill popper he was a womanizer he
enjoyed humiliating his staff this is
why he would conduct White House
meetings while sitting on the toilet in
order to embarrass and humiliate the
Kennedy holdover Ivy League aides who
who were still serving on the White
House staff the purpose of this was not
just his crudeness the purpose was he
did it because he could he did it
because he enjoyed the discomfort that
it caused others anybody
who wants to understand the the the
psychopathic nature of Lyndon Johnson
merely needs to read my book the man who
killed Kennedy
the case against LBJ I'm not an attorney
but in that book I use eyewitness
evidence fingerprint evidence deep Texas
politics and a lot of insider knowledge
I think to make a compelling case that
Lyndon Johnson has the motive means an
opportunity to kill John Kennedy and his
actions immediately after the
assassination while I admit they are
circumstantial certainly bolster that
case Roger when you look at everybody
today both on the left and a right who
do you see as candidates where you say
those three have a shot in the next 20
years to be a president these three have
a shot next 20 years to be President is
there anybody you see that's a very very
difficult question there are a few
people that I think are potentially
promising you know it's very early
I like the idea and some people will
scoff but I don't really care if the
president is re-elected and I think he
will be in a very tough contest then
what I would like to see is for him to
appoint Donald Trump jr. as the
infrastructures are pay him $1 a year
and let him take on the project of
working with the with the the
stakeholders the unions municipalities
and states to rebuild our infrastructure
this is what Don from jr. does he like
his father is a builder and if over for
years he can prove himself in that job
he's got the family name
he's got the speaking ability he's
gotten the courage he is that he'll be
the Aged Jack Kennedy was he couldn't be
President now that's a lot of ifs but
but when he just comes down to talent
and courage I think he has those things
but there are there are others you know
if I had to pick the person in the US
Senate whose politics most closely
resemble my eye
have to say that would be Senator Rand
Paul now in the television age I think
he himself would admit that he is not a
candidate built for the television age
he's kind of rumpled almost looks like a
college professor and the way he dresses
he's far more interested in policy and
principle than he is you know the
weather his suit is pressed or not but I
like his politics and had I not been for
Donald Trump who I had certainly an
antecedent commitment to I probably
would have voted for Rand Paul as the
person I most closely identified with
someone deeply suspicious of the erosion
of our civil liberties and the fact that
the government spying on us it's keeping
meta data information on our emails on
our phone calls on our text messages now
they're tracking us through our cell
phones to see if we are exposed to the
virus or not really the reason they're
tracking us you're talking to somebody
that the government had under
surveillance for three years they say
two years but the New York Times says
three years I have reason to believe
three years is correct so they gave me
the full legal prattle aho examination
and as you know for almost two years
CNN MSNBC and The New York Times and The
Washington Post and the rest of the fake
news media said Roger stone will be
charged with treason Roger stone will be
charged with conspiracy against the
United States Roger stone will prove to
be the link between Russia and the Trump
campaign Roger stone will be charged
with mail fraud wire fraud aiding
abetting a felony before the fact cyber
crimes including unauthorized access to
a protected computer receipt and
dissemination of stolen data and after
examining every corner of my life my
family life my social life my personal
life my political life my business life
they could find no evidence of any of
those things which means they lie to
several federal judges to get the
warrants to violate my fourth
amendment rights so I'm very concerned
about this big government intrusion into
the privacy rights of the average
American what happened to me we're in
the flash of an eye you can lose your
voice your ability to make a living your
home your insurance your savings in the
blink of an eye if it can happen to me
believe me Patrick you can happen to you
or any other American
I saw similar thing happen to Bernard
Caracas wall when he was great we've had
Bernard Kerik on by 18 minutes well in
the past before it was interesting
seeing him go through the process by the
way what from where you're at right now
with your indictment obviously all the
stuff is public everybody's read about
it seen it you know it's it's not
something that hasn't already been
addressed where are you at with that how
are you feeling about how that's going
on so far right now well I think there's
a lot of misperceptions about the case
for two reasons one there was at the
time of my trial really pretty much of a
media blackout
but the only thing that got a lot of
coverage was my conviction so if you ask
the average person what it is that stone
was convicted of they don't know a lot
of you to tell you well Russian
collusion which of course I was charged
with lying to Congress which is kind of
laughable because comeyou lied to
Congress Brennan lied to Congress
clapper lied to Congress Muller lied to
Congress Rosenstein lied to Congress
McCabe lied to Congress page lied to
Congress struck lied to Congress and the
list goes on but the difference is they
lied about consequential things that
were material misstatements that I made
to Congress were completely immaterial
they didn't hide any underlying crime
this was a fabrication of Andrew
Weissman who made the mistake of leaving
his initials on the metatags on my
original indictment very artful but I
didn't get a fair trial first of all the
judge eliminated every powerful argument
that I could make I was not allowed
to raise the question of the misconduct
of the Special Counsel or the FBI or the
Department of Justice or any member of
Congress we now see the FBI misconduct
in the Flynn case I can tell you that
even though my case records are sealed
and I cannot talk about it the FBI's
conduct in my case it's every bit as
shocking and egregious but I was not
permitted to raise that I wasn't
permitted to raise the misconduct of the
Special Counsel the threats that they
leveled against my friends if they
wouldn't testify the way they were told
to I was not allowed to argue selective
prosecution just back despite the fact
that Muller and all these others Comey
etc had lied to Congress and I hadn't I
was not permitted to raise that defense
I wasn't permitted to prove which I
could have done with forensic evidence
an expert testimony that nobody hacked
the DNC the DNC was not the subject of
an online act now if you read my
indictment the first five pages are
based on that premise but the judge
denied me the right to miss prove or
disprove the underlying premise of my
indictment so it'd be like going into a
prizefight with both hands tied behind
your back and then of course as we now
know and then the judge gagged me so
that CNN and MSNBC could could create a
tsunami of disinformation and fake news
about me and my case and so on but I was
not permitted to respond as to destroy
your ability to make a living in your
reputation and then lastly we learned
after the trial that the jury forewoman
had posted on Twitter and Facebook not
just a tax on Donald Trump which by the
way alone would not would not disqualify
her but attacks on me personally
starting on the day I was arrested and
subsequently and that she hid those
during the period of jury selection
I believe she misled the court about
them
and therefore I was not given as the
Supreme Court requires a jury that was
both impartial and indifferent the only
person in the world who thought
differently was judge
Jackson in my case who said the opposite
in a decision I have appealed that
decision separately from the conviction
and I will win that appeal if I am still
alive by the time its heard since let's
just say you get charged let's say
hypothetically I'm in charge
let's just say you have to do the time
let's just say you're you know you're
going through the process and president
Trump you know comes in do you think he
will pardon you you know I really don't
know I can tell you this I have not been
promised a pardon I have not been
assured of a pardon I have been
encouraged by the things that he has
said publicly both on Twitter and on
interviews he knows I did not get a fair
trial he himself said it was a
miscarriage of justice and we now know
why I was targeted they knew by August
of 2017 that there was no rushing
collusion so why were they investigating
me after that day the reason is very
clear they came to me or to my lawyers
on July 24th of 2019 and they said it's
time for your client to come clean it's
time for your client to confess he needs
to think hard about the substance of
these 29 phone calls between himself and
Donald Trump during the 2016 campaign
and when he's ready to tell the truth
that they were really about Russia and
WikiLeaks well then we might be willing
to recommend to the judge that he served
no jail time if on the other hand he
isn't prepared to their words
re-remember we may we may issue a
superseding indictment and hit him with
more charges and my answer was quick and
easy I said no and my lawyer said you
understand how serious this is they
could add you know
any kind of additional charges and in
this case no matter how fabricated you'd
probably be convicted and I said well
that's the way it is I was not going to
bear false witness against the president
I was not going in I was not going to be
the ham in their ham sandwich for the
mother report I was not going to be the
the the false testimony on which they
based an impeachment and removed
somebody that I have not only deep
affection for but I hope I think even
today is among our greatest presidents
taking on the two-party duopoly and the
media it's not easy to be Donald Trump
but his faith hasn't wavered the hand of
God is on him let me assure you he's
been put in the right place at the right
time for a reason and I believe that
reason will become clear to all of us by
the end of his second term Roger let's
say he doesn't pardon you what do you do
are you okay with that if he doesn't
warn you well I'll have to pray for to
God for guidance in that case okay a
great deal I would be a political
prisoner okay I think people would know
that I think there would be very anger
among Trump supporters not at the
president but because the Justice
Department in two cases the Inspector
General of the Department of Justice has
recommended the criminal charges of
James Comey but mr. Comey has not been
charged if at the end of the day mr.
clapper mr. Brennan Susan Rice Samantha
Power's
this list goes on and on rod Rosenstein
by the way if lying to Congress is a
crime I watched Rosenstein today I found
13 things he lied about so when is he
being charged I just asked that question
I think that that that many of the
president's supporters will be upset
about the two-tier justice in this
country if you are a Democrat and a
supporter of Hillary Clinton you can
pull off an abuse of power that that is
far worse than what we saw in Watergate
I saw this windbag from Illinois Richard
Durbin today
saying you know instead of talking about
the danger of this virus or poverty and
the fact that our cities are engaged
we're here talking about a rehash then I
went back and looked at what he had to
say about Watergate when he was running
for you I said at 1972 and it was the
worst constitutional crisis in the world
let's be very clear in Watergate there
was never any evidence whatsoever that
the President of the United States knew
about or approved the break-in at the
water at the Democratic National
Committee the Democratic National
Committee was broken into by a small
band of private citizens who were former
intelligence operatives but were in
private life and they planted bugs that
never worked and never produced anything
in this case the full authority of the
United States government and the
incredible intelligence committees
capability for surveillance and the
court systems were legitimately used to
spy on the Republican candidate for
president the president-elect and the
President of the United States
this makes Watergate look as the
president said the other day like small
potatoes but to Senator Durbin it's no
big deal it was a big deal when Nixon
did it although it wasn't the crimes
weren't nearly this egregious but it's
not a big deal today please senator go
back to Illinois you're an embarrassment
to the US Senate by the way Senator
Durbin suggested that I should be called
before the committee to testify let me
say right now let's do it I'm ready you
and I Durbin let's go head-to-head I'd
be happy to humiliate you know it would
never happen know what's not they don't
want to hear the truth or as Jack
Nicholson said they can't handle the
truth what a movie so so so when's the
last time you spoke to Trump can you can
you actually have conversations with
President Trump or not at all no because
he's allowed his lawyers will not allow
it and my lawyers will not allow it not
gonna so I have to like many I have to
read the president's feelings by
watching his tweets and his public
comments we have many
jewelle friends so I have every reason
to believe that the president still
holds me in high regard look I think he
understands that I was targeted only
because of my loyal support for him and
I was targeted long after they knew
there was no Russian collusion to try to
come up with some basis to try to
impeach him Roger little Colin unlike if
I may say this with all the fenders
somebody may say there's a lot of other
people that also excited with him but
they're not indicted they're not going
through what you're going through right
now so the opposition may say you know
the argument of saying they don't like
the fact that I just sided with them
that's why but no I think it's closer
than that first of all I exchanged the
39 calls that they refer to were
telephone calls that lasted longer than
a half an hour that is not the total
number of telephone calls between Donald
Trump and myself during the 2016
campaign so therefore that premium that
creates a an avenue to to if we can get
stone to say what we want about these
phone calls we've got a witness against
Trump number one number two when I wrote
the book the Clintons war on women I
think I aggravated the Clinton East is
the woman who headed my prosecution
jeanne ray represented the Clinton
Foundation and Hillary Clinton in the
missing email case if that isn't a
conflict of interest I don't know what
is the the the Pampas bully corrupt
dirty cop Erin szalinski who then took
over my prosecution who committed many
crimes which will be a subject of formal
complaints to DOJ in the bar in Maryland
in DC this guy was Hillary Clinton's
County deputy counsel at the State
Department now the media keeps
describing them as on non-political
career prosecutors that is not true that
is not who they are
Jonathan Kravis the US attorney
assisting US Attorney process
you need me he was the deputy counsel in
the Obama White House abuse of power by
him in previous cases is well known his
his illegal abuses during the trial of
three of congressman Ron Paul's campaign
aides is epic
his defrauding of the court in my case
is a matter of public record for which
he will ultimately have to answer they
want to fight we will still fight even
if I have to do so from a prison cell
people who are giving to my Legal
Defense Fund it's Doan Defense Fund com
are fueling my efforts to prove the
truth and I must tell you Patrick
I think 65,000 Americans who are praying
for me who are praying for my family
who aren't sending me the money that has
sustained this fight because I have been
wiped out I have nothing I am literally
indigent I'll tell you what I have I
have the IRS knocking on my door wanting
back taxes at a time that they know I
have literally nothing but the clothes
on my back so let's just say President
Trump is watching this and he knows
there's pressure on him pardoning you
one on the side of people who supports
you and and also on the other side of if
they he does pardon you he's gonna get a
lot of heat knowing re elections coming
up and maybe Jared Kushner who is a
little bit more of a logical guy who
doesn't necessarily have maybe the
relationship that you have with Trump
since 1988 maybe Jared whispers and says
this is not a good time to part maybe
let's pardon in December or January
February if they're watching this are
you okay with the pardoning not taking
place anytime soon until 2021 you know
one of the first things I learned in
politics from Richard Nixon don't answer
hypothetical questions here's what I
know
Donald Trump is a person of great
fairness he's a great he's a he's a
person of great mercy and he knows
what's happened here but here's what I
also know nobody tells Donald Trump what
to do not Roger stone not Jared Kushner
not certainly not Steve Ben and nobody
and therefore he'll make I believe that
he will make the right decision at the
right time
and I pray to God that that will be
sooner rather than later but I'm you
know I'm not advocating anything other
than justice because I think it is
abundantly clear the president has noted
several times that I did not get a fair
trial when the jury forewoman is
attacking me in 2019 and then she erases
those posts to cover her trail
no reasonable lawyer believes that that
is correctly decided Jonathan Turley is
not a conservative or a Republican he
said stone isn't it is entitled to a new
trial on that basis in the Boston
Marathon bombing case the guy convicted
got a new trial because one of his
jurors was posting on social media on
the topic of terrorism not even that
case just the topic of terrorism my
juror had not a single Trump supporter
not a single Republican not a single
military veteran not a single
blue-collar worker not a single person
with less than a college education but a
majority with post college education
three appointees from the Obama and
Clinton administration's several people
who had personal relationships at the
Department of Justice or the FBI it was
by no means a jury of my peers knowing
knowing how he's wired I wouldn't be
surprised if he just decided to pardon
you tomorrow you know after all the mess
is going on to have the media go crazy
about the fact that your pardon but
let's just say he does if he pardons you
would you agree to get a tattoo of
Donald Trump instead of Nixon on your
back you know I was thinking of doing
Patrick you know understated do it right
I thought I would add Trump Goldwater
and Buckley to my back to have kind of a
Mount Rushmore Oakley I thought wow
Buckley on that list is he's one of a
kind they don't have too many Buckley's
nowadays so so so that means we should
be expecting some new tattoo this year
so and they say you can't just get one
tattoo on life but once you start one
there's a bunch that come afterwards
well from your mouth to God's ear
okay let's talk about a little bit of
the dirty politics all we hear about
from from the side of the people that
are not in the world of politics dirty
politics and it's very obvious I mean
you know you've done some very very some
would call some nasty tricks games
manipulation whatever it may be you've
done some interesting things when it
comes on to politics who do you think
plays dirty or politics the left or the
right Democrats or Republicans well you
know in 1960 the West Virginia primary
became very pivotal for John F Kennedy
so Robert Kennedy put together a piece
of literature attacking Jack Kennedy's
Roman Catholicism
he put Hubert Humphreys disclaimer paid
for by Humphrey for president and he
mailed it to every Catholic household
what would you call that I call that a
dirty trip would you call that a dirty
trick and then in the Wisconsin primary
he he would put out a mailing accusing
Hubert Humphrey of being a draft dodger
while Jack Kennedy was a war hero the
problem was Humphrey volunteered for the
service and he was turned down for
physical reasons now I call that a dirty
trick but I guess I'd say this they call
me a dirty trickster I don't think I've
done anything that's beyond the bounds
of my contemporaries but if I am one
that means I can spot one and the
Russian collusion hoax is the greatest
single political dirty trick in American
politics it is the harnessing of the
authority of the United States
government and the capability of our
intelligence agencies to spy on a
political opponent it's the use of the
government of the machinery for
political purposes its sedition its
treasonous and it's highly illegal would
you consider yourself a
hyper-competitive guy no question about
it
okay I hate losing it makes me puke so
would you say anybody in the game is
better at the game of politics and the
tricks behind marketing whatever it is
then
you anybody in the game well I think the
problem with politics is it looks easy
from the outside people I think don't
really recognize that political strategy
is a science that you you're not basing
anything on your instincts or your
feelings or even your own personal
beliefs you believe you based campaign
strategy on very sophisticated voter
research surveys that means polling but
the purpose of the polling is I think
widely misunderstood by the public it's
not to find out who's ahead and who's
behind those are actually the least
important numbers it's to find out what
of your core messages move otres what
what information is it that you can
communicate to voters that will get them
to vote for you and not your opponent or
to move from undecided to vote for you
then the second question you have to
answer is what's the most efficient way
to deliver this information let me give
you an example Joe Biden makes a great
comeback in the Democratic nomination
process in South Carolina because he
gets an almost monolithic
african-american vote do those
african-american voters realize that Joe
Biden is the father of the legislation
that has incarcerated more black people
for first-time nonviolent drug crimes
than anybody in history that the Biden
bill as he used to proudly call it which
men dated the absolutely mandatory harsh
penalties for the first time non violent
crime of possession of tiny amounts of
drugs for personal use is responsible
for the mass incarceration at this point
of millions of black people who are
trapped in our penal system with
extraordinarily long sentences which has
destroyed lives destroyed families
destroyed without any hope of
rehabilitation and if you're a
conservative it's costing taxpayer
millions of dollars to house and feed
incarcerate people who are not a menace
to society people who are not inherently
violent people who haven't been
convicted of a violent crime Joe Biden
he's the father of this he doesn't
recant he argued with a woman in New
Hampshire about how successful this
policy has been the war on drugs was
Richard Nixon's biggest single mistake
however it's Bill Clinton and Joe Biden
who turbocharged the war on drugs under
Nixon there were not mandatory penalties
a judge could take into consideration if
the housewife was caught with a small
amount of marijuana in her purse but has
to work a day and a night job to support
three kids should get a different
sentence than some gangbanger caught
with a quarter ounce of cocaine but
today a judge doesn't have that
discretion thanks to Joe Biden Joe Biden
who started his career as an opponent of
the desegregation of the Wilmington
school system that Joe Biden Joe Biden
whose son as Attorney General refused to
investigate the hangings of black men
all over southern Delaware saying that
it wasn't racially motivated when the
evidence is to the contrary so people
need to know Joe Biden's real record why
do I say this because I've seen polling
and it moves people now let's go to
question two
how do you impart that urban radio in
this country is both inexpensive and has
extraordinary reach to african-american
voters in every major swing state
Detroit Milwaukee Richmond Charlotte
Miami Fort Lauderdale
these motors are not difficult to reach
and the message that will get them to
see the real Joe Biden I was very happy
to see the president tweet about this
today it is a major and legitimate issue
when Joe Biden says I've always been a
great advocate for civil rights
number one he said he marched with dr.
King that is a lie he never marched with
dr. King and he has raced Maidan
throughout his career
when it benefited him so so let me ask
you this question since you were a Barry
Goldwater fan yourself and you read his
book on conservatives is in 1960 64 64
percent of African Americans voted for
the Democratic Party again in 1960 64
percent voted for the Democratic Party
fast-forward four years later 1964 92
percent did that means a lot of African
Americans were conservative at one point
pre Barry Goldwater there's a cold water
somewhat changed that right and today
we're at 88 percent Yes Mother I know
you're a fan of a Barry Goldwater so I'm
curious I know what you say about that
I'm asking this for a reason let's take
it let's take it from a larger context
if we may let me finish the question and
I want you to answer let me finish the
questions people I'm going with this the
reason why I'm asking this is because do
you think what Barry Goldwater did to
cause the Republicans to lose the
African American vote from 64% which
means 36% was open to voting Republican
African Americans to 92 percent today
it's 88 percent a big number
Charlamagne God says you know Democrats
just have the African American vote
right and then you hear Joe Biden say if
you vote for Trump you're not black my
question for you would be do you think
what Barry Goldwater did to cause the
Republicans lose a ton of
african-american votes to Democrats do
you think Joe Biden could cause
Democrats to lose a lot of votes to
Republicans with what he just said if
those voters if today's black voters get
the real information yes let me put in a
little broader context if I may
Eisenhower gets about a third of the
black vote in 1932 more black Americans
voted for Herbert Hoover than Franklin
Roosevelt the the black vote in America
was traditionally Republican why because
of the Civil War the Democratic Party
was the party of segregation the
Republican Party was the party of
emancipation that changed during the New
Deal freaking
comic reasons and a majority of black
voters started voting Democratic but
still a solid third of them still voted
Republican in 1960 running against Jack
Kennedy Nixon still retained 32 and a
half percent of the african-american
vote Jackie Robinson was campaigning for
Richard Nixon in 1960 in 1964 Barry
Goldwater who had personally
desegregated the family department
stores in Phoenix and who was a member
of the NAACP in Phoenix opposed the 1964
Civil Rights Act because he said it
violated the states rights that the
states needed to desegregate not the
federal government therefore he was
depicted by a monolithic mainstream
media as being anti civil rights despite
his record in Phoenix which was to the
contrary
now Richard Nixon bears some
responsibility here because in 1968 you
won't have to remember he has Humphrey
running to his left and he has George
Wallace running to his right he cannot
afford to lose votes to either one of
them so he basically they all talk about
the Southern Strategy that he
essentially said civil rights laws need
to be applied evenly busing in Boston is
just as wrong as busing in in South
Carolina racism in the Boston school
systems is just as a Greece's egregious
as the racism in the southern school
systems now he gets elected this is
where it becomes important Richard Nixon
desegregated the public schools at the
time he became president twelve
seventeen percent of them were
desegregated were segregated were
desegregated almost eighty-two percent I
guess were still segregated by the time
he left office that was about seven
percent no violence no bloodshed
desegregation Richard Nixon gave us
affirmative action affirmative action is
not a Johnson or a Kennedy policy
affirmative action is a Nixon policy
giving folks a leg up who had been
discriminated against for centuries I'm
the last conservatives that still
offends affirmative action who tripled
the funding for black colleges as
president who appointed more
african-americans to public office than
LBJ and John Kennedy combined Richard
Nixon who increased by 90 percent the
funding for civil rights law enforcement
at the Justice Department Richard Nixon
so I would say the record is more
important than the rest the rhetoric but
the rhetoric cost us a majority of the
african-american vote then there was no
particular effort made by more recent
Republican nominees McCain Romney they
offer no strategy for the cities they
offered no strategy for the improvement
of lives of black Americans and then
along comes Donald Trump in my opinion a
historic opportunity you have a growing
black middle class you had African
American and all minority unemployment
at the lowest point possible what do
African Americans want I have a lot of
african-american friends you know what
they want they want the same things I
want they wants they want to live in a
safe community they want good schools
for their kids they want Economic
Opportunity they don't want to be
employees they want to be employers they
want a piece of the American Pie and I
think the juxtaposition of Joe Biden's
record of incarcerating black people and
Ronald and Donald Trump's record through
the second chance act of freeing people
who are unfairly trapped in our penal
system for small nonviolent crimes is a
debate I want to have so so let me ask
you based on that your thoughts with the
tragic event that took place with George
Floyd and the cop of the Minnesota cop
that led to the rights and protesting
and that goes back to Rodney King March
of 91 I came to the States November of a
28th of 1990 exactly four months later
I'm living in LA Rodney King's event
takes place in a 92 the rights take
place we're talking 28 years difference
and we're experiencing similar type of
riots if not worse what do you think
these
happen for all of this to stop well
first of all I think the penalties
against those four cops are not nearly
severe enough third-degree murder No
much too much tougher this this cop
absolutely knew what he was doing and
the look on his face indicated to me
that he was enjoying it so I'm not
satisfied that justice has been visited
the the the the case of the one officer
who watched and did nothing
he needs to be prosecuted also that's
terrible but it's not as bad as the
three who actually engaged in what I
believe was a murder so justice hasn't
been done there I don't think the state
has brought strong enough charges
against those cops but I also recognize
that this event is being used to
legitimize anarchy and violence that has
nothing to do with the horrific murder
of George Floyd and that I think is
wrong
I saw Floyd's family today appeal for
peace to to appeal to people to abide by
the law I think that was a very
courageous thing do I deny that there's
still racism in our country no not
whatsoever but and it has to be
eradicated but the best social program
in the world is a good steady job and
upward mobility the best thing we can do
is give Economic Opportunity and equal
educational opportunity to all Americans
that's what I think Donald Trump is
committed to and that what what that is
what was working until these horrific
events which have the ability to change
the entire political calculus how much
do you think the the playbook the rules
for radicals the book Saul Alinsky how
much you think that book is being played
out nowadays do you think it's just a
good book being written or do you think
it's actually being put to use today
it's being put to use today the pallets
of bricks just happened to show up
really how about the buses to transfer
all these people around from out of
state who's paying for those you know I
did a show on a major cable network
recently
I was told by the producer by it by the
way there's one name you can't mention I
said who's that you can't mention George
Soros in any way while you're on please
of course I honored their request
because I was their guest I won't
mention the network but I don't
understand that if somebody is paying
for violence if they are paying people
who are advocating the Milan
assassination of the President on social
media platforms which is a crime if
somebody is paying for this these
attacks and this violence in our cities
though seems to me to be crimes and I
just a wonder where attorney general
Barr and his people are remember the
great lesson of Watergate I'm sure you
remember it because liberals said it
over and over and over again no person
is above the law
no person is above the law would that
not include Barack Obama and Joe Biden
who had full knowledge of the
unconstitutional and seditious effort to
remove Donald Trump based on completely
fabricated information it was fun to
watch rod Rosenstein try to run between
the raindrops today but he lied
repeatedly about numerous things what do
you expect in President Obama to be
talking about today I think he's given a
speech for the first time you know while
you know he's not an office has given a
speech today what do you expect in him
to talk about oh he'll talk about racial
justice which much of which I'll
probably agree with I hope that he will
seek to tamp down violence violence is
never the answer but beyond that I'm not
going to suggest what he might do he's a
man of enormous oratorical talent I'm
sure they'll do a good job but his
message will be the undercurrent of his
message will be a criticism of President
Trump I think you can pretty much
guarantee that you know we used to have
a tradition in this country that that
former presidents just did not criticize
current presidents before he took any
action in in Cuba Jack Kennedy called
white-eyes
our to ask his opinion for example and
presidents have often consulted with
their predecessors they don't have to
but there was a certain comity yesterday
I saw George W Bush put out I guess it
was a letter criticizing Donald Trump
this isn't surprising George W you and
your entire family who plundered the
United States government voted and
endorsed Hillary Clinton so why should
we listen to you about anything it's I
mean you got also realized that the
opposite could be when he was asked
President Trump was asked have you
called Barack Obama to ask advice on
anything says no I don't need to I don't
I'm fine what I'm doing so even
President Trump didn't want to make that
phone call to Trump so some may say
Roger I understand the point you're
making with John F Kennedy Colin I but
at least even Trump is not calling Obama
well but but I can authorize the illegal
surveillance of John Kennedy then that's
a different story yes so you know going
back to what you're talking about here
when it comes onto the politics side you
know and people are going through this
politics out one of the things I'm
always curious about when I look from
the outside is who the power players you
know the whole puppet which some people
are controlling it is it is it
candidates that are the most powerful
people is that the money backers is that
the lobbyists is that the media is it
former presidents Roger you've been in
this game for a long time who are the
most powerful people that get to control
a lot of the decisions that are being
made in politics well there's no
question about the extraordinary power
of the media that power continuum
shifted in 2016 it's only through the
rise of a robust vibrant alternative
media based in the internet that Donald
Trump is able to communicate around the
national networks and around the
established corporate owned media
directly to the people and get elected
that's why you see this systematic
campaign of censorship on all media
platforms social media platforms of
Republicans and conservatives and
libertarians and Christians and anyone
really who isn't a liberal it's a
violation of the aunt
I trust laws the lawsuits that had been
brought against Twitter and Facebook on
First Amendment grounds have not fared
well in the ports but there are solid
antitrust issues here and all attorney
general bar needs to do is initiate
immediate antitrust action and Twitter
and tell them I'm sending marshals to
shut your operation down unless you stop
he has that authority needs to be used
if you really have that authority and
they're clearly violation violating
antitrust law they have a monopoly and
they're protecting their monopoly who
hasn't won I guess the tactic that they
have used to disadvantage competitors
like say gab or parlor or telegram are
easily findable I sat in the room for
the hearings of the House Committee
Judiciary Committee on internet
censorship and I watched the the
chairman of Google lie to Congress
repeatedly under oath ironically the
charge that I'm the crime that I'm
charged with China he said I couldn't
even find China on a map I'm not doing
any business in China
I know our our phone app doesn't trace
people even lies while isn't he charged
this is a game the censorship of non
Trump supporters is a major issue in
2020 you now see them finally and I
predicted this beginning to censor or
comment on the president's tweets
relying on the Washington Post to say
that there is no ballot fraud in a mail
in a mail-in election that's like asking
Jack the Ripper to massage your neck
it's ridiculous it's it's a joke let's
be clear virtually nothing reported by
The Washington Post is either true or
accurate this one reporter rods elderman
is one of the great fiction writers of
all time so nothing written by that
newspaper can be relied upon it's not a
news organization it's a propaganda
organ there's no evidence
outside elements are ginning up these
riots I'm not quoting their headline
exactly but I think it's pretty close no
that's wrong that's false that's not
true
that's not news that's crap Roger when
it comes out to dennis prager are you
familiar with Dennis Prager University
so you know the whole topic about
censorship and you to ban what's taking
place and videos being taken down I was
speaking to them about the fact that you
know what really happened and I pulled
up the loss the lawsuit and I read the
whole thing where eventually was
dismissed and they don't really consider
it because there's a difference between
freedom of speech by the government
versus freedom of speech of what you can
say on a company private enterprise they
can choose to take whatever they want to
take down or whatever they don't want to
take down so if that's the case can
YouTube do or to Twitter do or Facebook
do anything they want to do because suck
took a different approach where suck
said I don't think if Facebook is not a
defect checking business you said this
last week on Fox if you saw that so what
is your opinion on censorship when will
YouTube can and can't do the phone
company is a privately owned company but
they're regulated I mean if you're
serving the public I think you can be
regulated as a conservative I don't like
regulation generally speaking but if
that's the only way we can ensure fair
access I believe tallied emptor let the
consumer decide what he or she believes
or he or she wants to read I got a
message from a guy this morning who
simply put up a meeting on Instagram
they said pardon Roger stone and he was
the platform like that I've been on
Facebook for a long time my facebook
page for stone cold truth which is my
website where I post political opinion
as a hundred and sixty-five or 150
thousand followers during the election
if I posted something I wrote it would
get six hundred seven hundred a thousand
reach you know shares it would get
literally thousands of readings now I
get three four seven do you really think
we're that stupid I mean these things
are
being manipulated at the backend through
shadow banning and so on has to be
stopped I got two things nobody should
have fair access to the to the Internet
don't care if you're a socialist or or a
progressive or a vegetarian it doesn't
matter to me but the people decide what
they want to read what they want to
believe by the way it's so interesting
listening to and seeing how similar
style of communication you and President
Trump have on how you guys speak if I
can put him over you know watch it's
such similarities by the way stones
rules let's wrap this up we'll do
speedrun and we'll be done with this
interview here so stones rules I'll go
through ten of them and you tell me out
of these ten a which of them are by far
your favorite and most important one
number one it is it better to be very
hard it's gonna be very hard I'm curious
about what you're gonna say it is better
to be infamous then not to be famous at
all that's rule number one number two
past is prologue prologue okay now you
add an adjective to it but past is
prologue number three attack attack
attack never defend number four business
is business
number five only thing worse in politics
than being wrong is being boring you
talked about it earlier number six
reinvent yourself number seven nothing
is on the level number a think big be
big number nine hate is more powerful
motivator than love and number ten to
win you must do everything which one do
you think is the most important one well
first of all it's important to
understand that most of those are
written within the context of a
political campaign now some of them are
transferable to life overall but they're
but they're all important in their own
way I could not really pick one rule
over another because they're
interconnected they all work together my
book stones rules was not written for
conservatives or Republicans or
Christians it was written for everybody
doesn't matter whether you're in
entertainment or tech or agriculture or
on Wall Street this is a book that I
think can benefit everybody these are
the simple lessons that I have learned
is a warrior with 40 years in the arena
and I think they work for everybody men
and women now there's some style tips in
there for men that won't work for women
but beyond that these are just rules of
the road it's like a handbook I commend
it to anybody who wants to succeed how
do I get through my current ordeal and
my struggle with a out of control
federal prosecutors by following the
rules in this book which is probably the
second greatest book ever written after
the Bible love your humility it's a very
big strength of you it's very obvious
how many how many of those rules apply
to business how many do those reply to a
lot of them I think apply to business
you know tells you how to how to budget
an internet media campaign is in there
there's a lot of practical advice in
there as well as philosophical advice by
the way this is not the best book I've
written that was a joke I'm gonna I'm
gonna put the links below for your
Lyndon Johnson book and some of the
other books a you talk we'll put the
links below you know one thing out I
wonder about you is you've come up and
it's attack attack attack never defend
you know it's a very cutthroat super
competitive you were not worried about
stepping on anybody as long as you want
do you think right now looking back
upset with Ditka and I wonder how did
the process with when he was coming up
you know Ditka doing his interviews from
the Bears as a you know coach you just
call everybody out and he challenge
people and it's pretty strong opinions
and even with the last dance documentary
would Michael you're seeing how he was
and I pushed his people challenged
people pissed a lot of people off on
your way up in politics you've created a
lot of enemies many of them many many
enemies do you have so many what ends in
somebody losses that's the way politics
works yeah well you're cutthroat meaning
you had no sympathy for beating
everybody I mean you're a hyperbolic no
I think that's unfair here's what I'm
trying to say I when I say attack attack
in any campaign the candidate who
dominates the dialogue from the
beginning to the end will win you have
to force the other person to talk about
what you want to talk about
if you end up talking about what they
want to talk about you will lose so by
being aggressive by going on the attack
by by delineating the agenda and what
the campaign is going to be about you
will win that means you have to draw
first blood you have to lay down the
predicate for any campaign a campaign on
defense is losing votes a campaign that
is explaining is losing votes a campaign
that has no forward motion is losing
votes politics is motion that's one of
the rules in the book you have to create
the perception that your campaign is
gaining steam that you are moving
forward that you are attracting
supporters perception is reality it's
your job to create that perception and
you create it created by taking the
initiative that is what I'm trying to
say in that rule yeah when you outsmart
the other guys you make enemies Tom Kane
was the Governor of New Jersey he's a
great man
he ran in a primary with nine opponents
and some of them were very substantial
established politicians with long
records of distinguished public service
and he was a former leader of the State
House he won
they lost I had one friend and eight
enemies that's the way it is so you
don't think that's the reason why you
have a lot of people right now that I
wanted to take you down you don't think
because you've created so many different
enemies that I've teamed up to get it to
say it now it's our turn let's let's get
even with Roger well I'm certainly that
there are some who have revenge look I
wrote a book the bush crime family and I
wrote about the Clintons war on women
I'm an equal-opportunity
truth teller and I'll say things are
popular
you know Jeffrey Epstein has been in the
news a great deal over the last year if
you go to my book the Clintons war on
women the longest chapter is on Jeffrey
Epstein and every single thing you have
learned in the last year was written
back in 2016 Bill's 28 trips on the
Lolita Express bills 17 I think is the
right number
visits to Epstein's pedophile island the
fact that George Mitchell and Bill
Richardson and others were enjoying the
company of underage children it's all in
my book but the mainstream media didn't
cover my book so now that it was that it
was covered really because the
courageous reporting of a man
investigated reported with the Miami
Herald a woman named Brown who did an
amazing job of dogged ly staying on this
case because she knew something wasn't
right now everybody knows but back then
nobody knew so all in my book have you
watched a docu-series of Jeffrey Epstein
or no you haven't gone through da okay
so let's do speed round a Roger I'll
give you a name tell me one word that
comes to your mind one word that comes
to mind John Davis Lodge the smarter of
the two Lodge brothers he was Henry
Cabot Lodge his brother one of my
mentors prozac's actor diplomat
congressman governor very successful
actor president Truong courageous ballsy
Hillary Clinton criminal Joe Biden
racist scary Moochie nice guy Kushner I
saw a man wearing a suit I said hey
MOOCs that's a great-looking suit what
does it cost in a man-size Kushner I
like what he's done on criminal justice
I think he's done a great job robert
muller befuddled not all their cover-up
artists for the deep state
anthrax 9/11 it's all there Michael
Flynn a great American patriot the only
guy in America I can think of who's been
screwed worse than I have James Comey
epically corrupt pompous and I wonder
why he hasn't been charged and I have
Giuliani the greatest mayor of New York
City ever had a straight shooter and a
friend
Lewandowski I'm softening on this you
know he and I were pretty bitter
enemies we have a different approach but
I liked the fact that he has the courage
to defend the president at all places
Makaveli I've read his book many times
and if you read stones rules a number of
my rules are with acknowledgement based
on his paw man afford all mana for is a
comprar complicated a strategic genius
when it comes to convention politics I
don't recommend his business practices
Richard Nixon resilient persisted the
greatest comeback in American history
Charles black a savvy Washington
operator Jim Messina I'm thinking
atheneum you don't know that name
Kennedy that is Ross Perot a trailblazer
people forget the fact that he actually
led both bush and gore for some period
of time in that election proving that if
you had enough money a third party
candidate could win an early precursor
to Trump in the sense that a businessman
running for president first time that's
ever gotten any real traction I know
these aren't work one-word answers but
it's tough
oh good Mark Cuban I like him he's
audacious he's a businessman like Trump
I never quite understand where he stands
cuz sometimes he's Pro Trump sometimes
he's critical but he's always
interesting I like I like watching him
George sorro's evil the personification
of evil Eliot Spitzer a hypocrite a man
who was prosecuting guys for seeing
prostitutes while he himself was seeing
prostitutes Andrew Cuomo tough neck
Sounion in many ways unforgiving
politically talented kind of ruthless
has a shot for presidency it's very hard
to say I mean because they have delayed
some of these late primaries it's not
inconceivable that Biden could get to
the convention with not enough votes to
go over the top on the first ballot if
Biden were to fall
short on the first ballot he won't be
the nominee somebody else will 2024 do
deserve a shot in 2024 Cuomo probably
he's got to get reelected governor the
history on that is not good people have
gone for a you know the fourth term in
New York have not politically
historically fared well in the past
Nancy Pelosi frozen face what's wrong
with her face Roy Cohen complicated
vicious sentimental extraordinarily
loyal photographic memory
tough his nails and last but not least
Roger stone one word a guy who always
did his best and a fighter who will
never quit how ugly are these this
year's campaign going to be this
presidential campaign this year how ugly
will again you know it'll be very ugly
but there has to be a context when
Lincoln ran they had handbills posted
that said that he had fathered a black
child and they handed them out today we
use the internet and television but it's
just as vicious politics in America is a
contact sport it always has been it
always will be so I don't expect it to
be anymore vicious than the one four
years ago and the one four years before
that I don't one four years before that
on through our history the only thing
that's changed is our technological
capability to deliver the message just
change a game social media is a
completely changing game Roger we're
gonna put the links to all your books
below and I'm gonna put the link to the
GoFundMe website you were talking about
is well we'll put that link below as
well thank you so much for coming and
visiting us on by teaming and being a
guest I'm glad to be here and thanks to
my friend Josh Feuerstein for putting us
together this has been a great
opportunity because as I say I have a
lot to say thank you for your time so
you know it's not often you see a
long-form interview taking place with
Rogers snow especially right after him
being indicted I think this is the first
long-form if not the longest interview
he's done for a couple hours where we
talk about a broad of issues his
relationship would Trump people he's
worked with in the past the stone
all these other things that we discuss I
want to hear your thoughts on what you
took away from today's interview click
below and comment on what you took away
as well as if you watch this interview
and you liked the topic you liked the
dialogue I have two other interviews I
want you to watch one of them is with
Bernard Kerik who was the former a chief
of the police department in New York
NYPD and he had he had a very very
strong reputation at a time when they
cleaned the streets of New York or the
other anyone would be with Ron Paul Ron
Paul talks about how he came about his
philosophies with politics if you've not
watched this one click over here if
you've not watched a Bernard Kerik one
click on that one and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye
[Music]